superhero movies might be the biggest
thing at the box office today
and with the kind of epic action that
we're getting from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's easy to see why that
hasn't always been the case though the
history of the genre is full of
catastrophic failures that never managed
to save the day for audiences or critics
from obscure heroes who are a little too
bizarre to household names that had a
rough road to the screen here are the
worst superhero movies ever made
barbed wire barbed wire might not be a
traditional superhero but with her
over-the-top costume dystopian sci-fi
setting and roots on the page she seemed
like the perfect comic book character to
make Pamela Anderson an action star in
theory in practice the 1996 adaptation
didn't give the fans or the cast
anything they wanted except maybe seeing
Anderson in the leather costume that
telegraphed called unnecessarily
reviewing set in the distant future of
2017 the movie starred Anderson as
barbed wire a bartender and bounty
hunter tried to escape the second
American Civil War by dealing with a
mobster named big fatso
and making enough money to move to
Canada with a premise like that it's
easy to see why Anderson thought she was
signing on for what she called a dark
comedy about a blonde big haired badass
riding around on a motorcycle with a
studio demanding changes to the script a
new director and less humor however what
could have been a campy classic was
tanked from the start
Howard the Duck you might have been
excited to see Howard the Duck pop up in
the post-credits scene in guardians of
the galaxy but don't let your interest
in one of Marvel's more obscure
characters trick you into watching his
first feature film outing from 1986
produced by George Lucas yes that George
Lucas the movie starred back to the
futures Lea Thompson giving it a sci-fi
pedigree that any movie in the 80s would
have been jealous of unfortunately while
Universal was trying to get the guy who
made Star Wars they got the guy who made
the Phantom Menace instead I don't know
is what the hell I'm doing here
after Robin Williams wisely passed on
the role the job of voicing Howard went
to theater actor chips sign who knew
something was wrong when he had to buy
his own ticket to see the movie he
starred in as he later said in an
interview by the time they'd gotten
through 111 minutes of a duck puppets
questionable romance with Marty McFly's
mom
he and his friend Roy were alone in the
theater everyone else had bailed how
would you really are the worst Green
Lantern with roles in blade Trinity and
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds has had decent
luck with superhero movies his attempt
at bringing DC's Green Lantern to life
in 2011 however risked ruining his
career and taking the whole superhero
genre with it after it cost a whopping
300 million dollars to make about 80
million dollars more than it took in the
scathing reviews and terrible box office
numbers threatened to turn Studios off
the idea of comic book movies altogether
fortunately for Reynolds and the entire
superhero genre the same weekend Green
Lantern opened he shot the now famous
Deadpool test footage that would
convince Fox to give him a shot at
redemption Reynolds took the chance and
unlike Green Lantern Deadpool was an
r-rated smash steal Black Panther
brought super heroics to Africa and
moviegoers into theaters in
record-breaking numbers and blade kicked
off the modern superhero film but
neither kinked chala Nord the daywalker
were the first black comic-book hero to
make it to the big screen it's often
overlooked but Shaquille O'Neal beat
them both to the punch when he starred
in the 1997 adaptation of DC steel
although you can't really blame anyone
for forgetting about this downright
awful movie it was so bad that director
Kenneth Johnson apologized for it
admitting that he probably should have
walked away once he found out who his
star was going to be Shaq definitely had
the heroic proportions to bring the
Superman inspired armored hero to life
but lacked the acting chops to save a
miserable script that feels like a bad
first draft of Iron Man as Johnson
revealed however Warner Brothers
co-president Bill Gerber opted for
O'Neal over the likes of Wesley Snipes
and Denzel Washington because he thought
Shaq would sell more toys considering
Gerber was fired the next year we're
guessing the toy sales weren't much
better than the movie spawn when you sit
down to watch a DVD commentary and the
first thing the director says is you can
blame it all on me that's not a good
sign
that's exactly how Mark V pay introduces
himself in the spawn commentary at the
time he was known as a visual effects
wizard but he'd never directed a movie
before and it showed
when den of geek
visit of the 1997 film they pointed out
that for a movie based entirely around
its visuals quote a good number of the
effects aren't good some are flat-out
awful as a former staffer at Industrial
Light & Magic the visual effects should
have been to pay specialty although as
far as he was concerned the CGI wasn't
the problem speaking to Wired in 1997
the outspoken filmmaker lashed out at
the censors claiming the MPAA is driving
a stake through my heart with this
because they're making me take this
movie down so much he also called it a
very positive story which is a little
hard to believe considering that it's a
movie about a zombie superhero getting
yelled at by a demon clown daredevil
long before he donned the Dark Knight's
cape and cowl in the DC film universe
Ben Affleck made his ill-fated foray
into the superhero genre with 2003's
daredevil despite a flex genuine love
for the character the cinematic version
suffered from the tonal whiplash of
ultra serious images mixed with goofy
action like the playground fight between
Daredevil and Elektra and a murder a
supervillain whose menacing insanity
came off as cartoonish and not in the
good way with a bad script and
incredibly awkward visual effects it's
no surprise that critics offered up some
unfavorable comparisons to spider-man
which hit theaters the previous year
they weren't the only ones Affleck
himself called daredevil the only movie
that he regrets making they agreed that
the 2015 Netflix version was doing the
character far better than a movie that
as he said quote never kind of got it
right the Fantastic Four
technically Roger Corman's the Fantastic
Four has never been released but this
low-budget take on Marvel's first family
became a thing of legend after bootleg
copies began making their way around the
convention circuit the story goes that
new constantine films contacted the
veteran b-movie producer after failing
to secure a 40 million dollar
partnership with 20th Century Fox nobody
else wanted in so since the rights to
the Marvel property would expire if a
movie wasn't in production by December
31st 1992 Corman was hired to make the
cheapest movie he could
god help us the result was a movie so
legendarily bad that it became the
subject of a 2015 documentary called
doomed from director Marty Langford
the saddest revelation in that film was
that the cast had no idea that they were
just making a movie to help secure the
rights and that there were never any
plans to actually release it and give a
cast of unknowns their big breaks you
can't blame them for being fooled but
they probably should have noticed
something was up when they could barely
hear dr. Doom's dialogue over the
clanking of his armor or you know when
they saw what the thing was supposed to
look like to be fair though the origin
story in this film is actually more
faithful to the comics than in any other
Fantastic Four movie to date of course
the fact that we still think this one is
the worst even after those other three
should give you an idea of just how bad
it is Catwoman if you watch Halle
Berry's notoriously terrible Catwoman
movie and Christopher Nolan's game
changer Batman Begins back to back it's
hard to believe that there was only a
single year between them this extremely
loose DC adaptation was nominated in
seven categories at the Razzies and
triumph sort of in four including worst
actress for Barry she even showed up in
person to collect the award along with
co-star Alex Borstein and her Academy
Award and started off by thanking the
studio for casting her in what she
called a god-awful movie and that was
the nicest thing she said about it in
that speech rest assured it actually is
that bad in addition to scenes where
Barry's magical cat powers kick in
during a basketball game and caused him
to swat at the ball like a ball of yarn
it's full of cringe-worthy stereotypes
for a female superhero seriously
Catwoman fights a villain whose big plan
is to distribute evil makeup because
she's mad that she's starting to look
old in 2018 Barry addressed Catwoman
once again while accepting the matric
award from New York women in
communication she acknowledged how bad
the picture was but she defended her
decision to accept the role revealing
that the quote blow to money she may
change
her life and that the movie taught her
what not to do
Captain America after 10 years of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's hard to
imagine anyone but Chris Evans as
Captain America back in 1990 though Matt
Salinger son of famed American author JD
Salinger was tossing shields when Evans
was still in elementary school
originally intended to be released on
the 50th anniversary of Captain
America's first appearance this
low-budget Marvel adaptation was never
actually finished with the production
running a ground before the final scenes
were shot unwilling to send the existing
footage to the deep dark vault that it
must certainly belonged in studio execs
had editors cobbled together a version
that could be released on VHS mr.
president
thanks Salinger later revealed that the
film was as ruling to shoot as it is to
watch with his rubber suit causing him
to overheat on top of that the custom
looked ridiculous thanks largely to the
addition of rubber ears attached to the
helmet and the movie's red skull was
inexplicably portrayed as an Italian
mobster complete with a hilariously
over-the-top accent that was a gun
this is a detonator did you really
expect me to be taken alive as for the
script well there's a scene where cap
grabs the red skull by the wrists and
the skull pulls out a knife and chops
off his own hand
not exactly the evil mastermind fans
were expecting condorman dubbed an
ideological intervention from the disney
machine by Time Out 1981's condorman is
a camp cocktail of Cold War spy thriller
comedy and superhero movie all watered
down for family consumption this misfire
from the mouse house stars Michael
Crawford as woody witkin's a comic book
creator who insists on doing everything
he writes in real life just to prove it
can be done after accidentally getting
involved with a seductive Soviet spy
Wilkins has to become the hero he
created flying in all for the most part
Crawford himself was in the ghastly
Condor man suit and at one point he
almost died in it after falling into a
river in costume the gigantic wings
dragged him down and nearly drowned him
making the film unpleasant on both sides
of the camera that said it's been more
than 35 years since Condor man hit
theaters maybe it's time to introduce
Disney's first attempt at a superhero
movie to the MCU or not